what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts
today I've actually done a coffee I have
bone broth I'm on a new
Health Journey
I'm very unsuccessful with my my
healthiness sometimes
but the way I see it
is try try try again
I'll try again and I'll fail I'll try
again and I'll fail I'll try again until
I get it I did this on social media okay
and it's how I approach everything in
life
is I don't care
if people are like you've tried a
million things I don't care if people
are like oh you failed at that that and
that
I'll keep trying till I six till I
succeed
now right now my goal for months has
been to lose 20 pounds
actually
I had a lot of different goals for 2022
but
because the YouTube channel got so big
so fast
um it was like that one goal on YouTube
was to hit 100
000 subscribers and I crushed that but I
didn't do a lot of my other goals which
one was to lose 20 pounds
um I did lose
like 10. 10. so yeah maybe I got like
half
um
um
but I couldn't the next 10 I just could
not
seem to shed I don't know what I was
doing like I was like
it's probably my coffee which is now
gonna be bone broth and you guys have to
hold me accountable for this
okay let's talk about my face I know
everyone's gonna ask what happened to
your face what happened to your face
now this is the dumbest way that I've
ever got hurt in my life one of them so
I had a volleyball game on Saturday and
I was kind of running late anyway I was
like half asleep
and I went I have this big water bottle
okay you guys have seen it
and what I wanted to do was I wanted to
grab a water bottle that was cold from
the fridge to pour into there
now where did this go wrong
the water bottle was in
um the drink fridge which is like the
drinks for guests so usually like those
water bottles are for gas not for me but
that day I was just feeling frisky I
don't know so I grabbed the water bottle
and it hit a beer bottle
and I was bending over to grab it and
the beer bottle shattered on the floor
and the glass came in my face and
luckily the only one that really like
dug in was on my nose lucky and unlucky
I was like no
not my money maker girl no no why God
but I was thinking about it and it could
have hit my eye and I could be blonde
right now so
I was like life comes at you fast it
comes at you fast
yeah so it's just been crazy my last
coffee thought I was in a I was very
tired uh last coffee thought I did
I thought I was going on a trip to Dubai
turns out I can't get into Dubai because
my passport is
um gonna expire within six months so
sad but you can't win them all sometimes
in life you take owls and I was very
disappointed but I should be in Dubai
right now but I'm still in freaking
London
I don't really like London anymore I
want to leave but I can't for a minute
um anyways another thing so
auntie
has been helping me become a better
woman
and I always get this
Elliot what are you doing
so she was telling me I lack discipline
and I'm a really hard worker so at first
I was like but then I was like you know
what I probably do lactis but I've been
talking about how I'm gonna quit coffee
for a very long time and I don't quit it
now I'm drinking bone broth and auntie
and blessing don't think I'm capable of
quitting coffee like that and it's like
I want to do it more now Ellie
hey hey Ellie stop
come here sit chill out Jesus anyways um
so
and she said you lack discipline you
stay up too late after shows you should
go to bed right after shows
I do I like to chit chat sometimes I'll
be chit chatting with guests I don't
know I
I
she also said that I have no excuse
because she does all this stuff and
she's disabled
yeah and she was right honestly I was
like hmm okay you're right you're right
you're right you're right so
um Auntie's been helping me and we're at
filming episode two of wife school where
she's going to show me how to eat and
cook for a family of like four or
something on a budget
so that'll be exciting
um on top of that
on top of that Auntie um
she also is gonna have me weigh in
before break and when I come back for a
break I'll have to have lost
we haven't decided a number yet but
we're gonna she's gonna hold me
accountable and I'm trying to be the
best version of me oh third thing she's
doing this is kind of crazy okay
she wants to know how I am on dates
this makes me the most nervous
because
I just get
I'm awkward okay I'll tell you that but
so what she's gonna do is she's vetting
men and if you're interested in this
DM Auntie Jenny on Instagram
um you can find her Instagram just go to
my following and put Jenny or Auntie
she'll come up like the people I follow
um anyways
and she's gonna find guys that she's
gonna interview first have me go on
dates with and then get feedback from
the guys about how I am on dates
um and she's looking more for guys that
don't know who I am so
maybe maybe I don't know but you know
um
it'll be an interesting project because
then it's like she's like then you can
figure out what you have to work on
and I was like that's a good idea
but I'm nervous I'm so nervous oh my
gosh I'm nervous
um
yeah
um anyways
in other news I'm going home for
Christmas semi soon
um
I don't actually know when but like I'm
buying a flight
probably the 20th or the 21st I'm going
home I'm gonna spend some time with the
family I don't know if you guys know
this but I have
um nine siblings so it's nice because I
can go home and like spend time with
them and I have
um two brothers that I grew up in
between that I I particularly like one's
named Austin and one's named Adam
um
I I was the girl like in between them so
I think that's why I'm a little bit of a
tomboy but
Adam is like
he never needed red pill content like
they've both done very well with women
Austin has been with his girlfriend for
like three years he sees my older
brother and he just got engaged and Adam
my younger brother
um he
he's like always had women just yeah
love him I don't know so I was thinking
I was thinking about how my brothers
just end up with the type of women that
they talk about they want in red pill
like it was crazy my older brother
Austin knows nothing nothing of this red
pill stuff he doesn't care he doesn't
give a [ __ ] and his girlfriend
went to culinary school for fun
just for fun like she's an engineer and
she was like yeah I just want to go to
culinary school without even asking she
does his laundry cleans code like does
all that [ __ ] and I'm just thinking like
Austin's never asked her to do any of
that
he just is good with women I guess I
don't know
I'm trying to think of what else yeah
I've also guys I'll show you what I've
been doing
I got a lot of complaints on my posture
from the wife school video let me know
how I can be more more wifey guys
um but
I've started wait I've started walking
with the book on my head
and I see where my posture has gone
wrong because I'll be walking
and
this absolutely does fall all the time
I'm doing good right now
yeah
let's see let's see if I can
ah
oh my God uh no okay well you guys see
it's a work in progress but yeah auntie
um has been helping me improve my life
and I think she's right I think I gotta
I gotta work on some stuff I gotta
she said I need to stop swearing
and then I'm like
she said I gotta stop swearing she said
we gotta work on your femininity a
little bit
she said
I gotta eat better
um I need to stop frivolously spending
money on coffee she's like it hurts me
every time I see your coffee thought
videos I'm like
and I'm like Auntie but I do well that's
like the only thing I spend money on she
said it doesn't matter it's not what
traditional women do I was like oh
yeah so that's what's going on in my
life
um
yeah let me know what you guys think
what else should we put in wife school I
don't know
um
I'm sorry this is on my face I'm like
It's Gonna Leave a scar I just know it I
just know it
um but it's okay whatever
um
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
Bell I'll talk to you next time